a Zelda game without link is uh not a
Zelda game actually which is kind of
weird since he's not even the character
that the series is named after top 10
anime betrayals number one but seriously
though Zelda is not Zelda without link
and if I were to ask you how many links
there are in the franchise I'm curious
what would your guess be go ahead guess
I'm about to tell you the answer but
first I'd like to thank the sponsor of
this video struct have you ever wanted
to make a game even just for fun but you
feel like you can't because that
requires all sorts of sick coding skills
and paid programs well stop thinking
that because struct is here to solve
both of those things it's a completely
free app that you can download on the
Google Play store or the Apple App Store
that lets you turn your ideas into games
super easily with zero coding skills
necessary I mean look at me I made an
army of lovely ladies to destroy my
enemies in bloodthirsty battle fly my
Valkyries fly for me and a lot of people
are doing it over 2 million in fact you
can play other people's games comment on
them and of course share your own or
play with friends or if you're not sure
what to do you can always play the
flagship game struck Showdown to your
heart's content to get a feel for
everything struck can do including
letting you pick your own character
that's me I'm the grass dude just don't
expect to be as good as I am and since
struck is extremely responsive to their
Community with constant feedback and
updates what are you waiting for click
the link in the description to download
struct for free today and start making
Valkyrie armies or whatever else you'd
like to make and now on to the video
okay you ready with your answer the
answer is there's actually only one Link
in the entire franchise he just goes
through time and is known as the hero of
time and solves the world's problems in
every iteration nah I'm just kidding
there's like 12 of them well 12 playable
ones anyway and they all have their own
Origins and stories and I know what
you're thinking yeah Bandit there may be
12 links but I mean come on how
difficult can Link's lore be they're all
just simple kids that become Heroes
right well yes but also no they each do
have their similarities but they also
all come from different places and end
up in different places and even span
multiple games sometimes so it's worth
worth it to know who's who and I thought
I'd make a shorter video covering
exactly that for each and every playable
Link in the series and if you're a fan
of any of the games I'm sure this will
be of interest to you oh and spoiler
alert for the entire series obviously
playable link number one the hero of the
Skies around the age of 17 when the game
takes place this kid has no parents at
least none that we know of seriously
it's weird how many of these games have
just no mention at all of Link's mother
or father this link is just some
skyloftian kid who grew up in skyloft
and aspires to become a skyloft knight
which are combat and survival trained
Knights who ride atop Loft wings and
ensure the safety of everyone living in
skyloft and the surrounding floating
islands although I'm not sure why
necessarily skyloft needs Knights I mean
it's not like there are many monsters up
here terrorizing the place aside from
those evil cat monster things that I
loathe but anyway he had a normal life
you know for someone living up in the
clouds he even had a school bully which
is unfortunately kind of normal which is
depressing to say it's also heavily
implied via demise's dialogue at the end
of the game that the hero of the Skies
is The Reincarnation of the spirit of
the first hero who was also just some
dude that was the chosen champion of the
Goddess highly in the early days when
highly a waged battle against demise an
act which would forever tie the
bloodline of the goddess to the spirit
of her chosen hero Skylink is perhaps
the most important Link in the franchise
aside from the hero of time due to the
fact that he is responsible for forging
the goddess blade into the master sword
and defeating demise the original big
bad wolf and he and Zelda may have
repopulated the surface of the Earth but
anyway moving on playable link number
two the hero of the Minish which is
actually just a fan made title that he
doesn't actually receive in game but
this guy again is just some kid around
the age of 12 who's a blacksmith in this
game or at least the grandson of a
blacksmith known as Smith the blacksmith
he's childhood friends with the Princess
Zelda and just ends up in the wrong
place at the wrong time really when he
accompanies her to the pcori festival
which is interrupted by vati finding and
destroying the pcori blade as well as
turning Princess Zelda into stone her
father King then tasks the hero of
diminish with reforging the pcori blade
and breaking the curse on Zelda and the
rest is history Minish history playable
link number three the hero of four which
is a fan made name from me I know naming
link is one of my many gifts but anyway
this link is one of the links with the
least amount of backstory and that he's
literally just there for some reason he
just accompanies Zelda one day to check
out the pcori blade which now goes by
the name the four sword due to the
events in the Minish Cap since this is
many years after the Minish Cap but does
deal with the same villain in the same
blade it can be assumed that this link
also has a similar backstory to the one
in the Minish Cap perhaps he's also the
grandson of a blacksmith and the
childhood friend of a Zelda playable
link number four the one the only the
hero of time be honest you've heard that
catchy title before regardless of if
you've played the game and for good
reason too because aside from the first
hero of the sky the hero of time is
perhaps the most important Link in the
entire franchise because of his
Adventure directly leading to the
infamous timeline split as well as
ganondorf's many different returns
because of of his importance to the
story as a whole his adventures are
referenced even in breath of the wild
and any references to the ancient hero
or legendary hero in the games following
Ocarina of Time are likely references to
the hero of time we also know a bit
about his backstory from in-game quotes
as well according to the Deku Tree
Sprout link is a Hylian who was given to
the great Deku Tree to be raised in the
Kokiri Forest as a Kokiri for safe
keeping by his mother who narrowly
escaped the hyrulean civil war with just
enough time to save her baby boy before
succumbing to her fatal wounds since
Link's father is never mentioned in
Ocarina of Time but in other games is
referred to as a knight of Hyrule it can
be assumed that the hero of times father
likely fought and died in said Civil War
as a knight of Hyrule the hero of time
is also the same link that continues
onward into the events of Majora's Mask
after he's done ridding the world of
Ganondorf before he has a chance to mess
things up he apparently then leads a
quiet life in servitude to the Hylian
royal family following the events of
Majora's Mask and shows up later on in
the timeline as a fully grown adult
ghost who is a side character to the
next playable game link enter the hero
of Twilight link number five this link
is the only Link in the entire series
who is directly confirmed to be a blood
descendant of the hero of time as proven
by the fact that he inexplicably already
has the Triforce of courage in his blood
and the hero of time or wrath of the
hero Shades dialogue 2 Link the hero of
Twilight is also a teenager around the
age of 16 to 17 that has no in-game
mention of his parents just like the
hero of the sky and many other links he
grew up in the little village of Ordon
as a farmhand and for whatever reason is
fascinated with swordplay and is
actually very proficient at it despite
having very little actual experience in
that particular field you know prior to
the events of the game speculation tells
me that this could mean that his father
may have also been a sword fighter like
he's implied to be in other games and
that he died when link was very young
leaving the little hero with an inner
desire to be like his father no idea
about his mom though another piece of
speculation is that the hero of
Twilight's farmhand nature and knowledge
of opponent's song is proof of the hero
of times marriage to melon who is a farm
girl who created oppona's song but
that's neither here nor there playable
link number six the hero of light from
four Swords Adventures in this final
game that deals with vati the evil wind
Mage and the four sword and just like
the extremely similarly named game four
Swords the Hera of light does not really
have a backstory but rather just kind of
pops up when needed at the start of the
game again inexplicably connected to
Princess Zelda and the six maidens I
choose to believe that these three four
sword wielding links all have the same
backstores because parallel lore is good
lore in my opinion and once again that
would mean that link was Zelda's
childhood friend and is the grandson of
a Smithy named Smith but that's just my
guess changing timelines playable ink
number seven would be the hero of wins
who is the first link in the adult
timeline now this is where Link's
backstory starts to get pretty
interesting but let's start with what we
know for a fact about this link
according to aunuma directly he's meant
to be around 12 years old which is
backed up by the Super Smash Brothers
Brawl Toon Link trophy link lives in the
adult timeline following a great flood
on an island known as outside island
with his grandmother and little sister
named Arrow again and though we're not
sure what happened to Link's parents but
since Errol is pretty young like maybe
around eight or nine years of age and
the two of them live with their
grandmother we can assume that something
bad probably happened to Link's parents
not too terribly long ago and that they
are permanently out of the picture
because of this hence why the kids were
then given to their grandmother for
safekeeping instead but now for the fun
part his theoretical non-connection to
the spirit of the hero this is a pretty
well known Theory but keep in mind that
it's still just a theory and you're free
to believe it or not depending on what
you feel like but anyway it's theorized
that unlike the vast majority of the
other links in the Zelda series the hero
of winds is actually not connected to
the spirit of the hero this is because
Princess Zelda in Ocarina of Time sent
the hero of time back in time spawning
the child and adult timelines and
removing the hero from the adult
timeline altogether this is also why the
Triforce of Courage and the Wind Waker
is scattered at the bottom of the ocean
because it shattered when the hero was
removed from the timeline unlike living
on within the hero's bloodline as proven
by the hero of Twilight in the child
timeline was that confused using okay
let me summarize real quick what this
means essentially is that the hero of
winds really was just some kid
completely disconnected from any heroic
Spirits or Bloodlines that came before
he just really wanted to save his little
sister and figured Ah hell why not save
the rest of the world while I'm at it
also after his adventure with Tetra
Zelda ends at the end of the game and
Ganondorf and the last king of Hyrule
are sealed away once and for all beneath
the waves the two actually go on another
adventure which spawns the events of the
Phantom Hourglass and takes place in
another ocean realm known as the world
of the ocean King it's actually pretty
similar to the Hyrule vs Terminus setup
but anyway that's the hero of winds in a
nutshell moving on the next playable
link so link number eight is the hero of
trains from The Game's Spirit Tracks
that takes place apparently 100 years or
so after the events of the hero of winds
in a new land called new Hyrule which
was founded by the hero of winds and
Tetra Zelda it's unknown if this link is
the descendant of the hero of winds
actually it's kind of improbable for a
reason I'll get into in just a bit but
either way he also does not have any
parents with him when we meet him in
game go figure he's just a kid from a
village known as Adoba Village and lives
with Nico the very same Nico that once
was a pirate serving under the pirate
Captain Tetra only he's an old man now
link is also The Apprentice of a master
train engineer named Alfonso who trained
link no pun intended into becoming a
royal engineer himself and the rest is
history the reason why I don't think the
hero of trains is physically related to
the hero of wins is because you'd think
that Nico would know if this link was
the descendant of the older link he even
tells link that he looks like the hero
of winds who he refers to as an old
friend of his anyway I guess the hero of
trains is to the hero of wins what the
hero of winds was to the hero of time a
disconnected but similarly Brave hero
that also goes to prove the absence of a
spirit of the hero in the adult timeline
well that and the complete absence of
any mention of the Triforce at all in
the game aside from some symbols with
the adult and child timelines out of the
way it's time to move on to the
problematic one the what if styled
alternate reality of the Fallen timeline
in this timeline or should I say in this
reality Ganondorf transformed into Ganon
and killed the hero of time in Ocarina
of Time leaving the job of sealing him
away up to the sages alone which worked
except for the fact that they kind of
sort of sealed him away within the
sacred realm and he corrupted the whole
thing turning it into the dark world but
what is this in all iterations of Canon
explained
no it's not so the next playable Inc
link number nine is the hero of Hyrule
from A Link to the Past who is another
of the more impactful links in the
series due to having the most games
under his belt that feature him in this
game link lives with his uncle again
with no parents to be seen but at least
we're getting closer the game starts
with Princess Zelda being captured by
Agony which is ganon's Alter Ego
telepathically communicating with link
and his uncle pleading them to come and
Aid her they both hear this calling
because they're both of the blood of the
Knights of Hyrule which is a clan of
Warriors said to be descendants of the
legendary hero which either refers to
the hero of time or the hero of the sky
either way Link's uncle is killed trying
to rescue Zelda so link takes up the
mantle and the rest is his history by
the way if you're interested in learning
more about Link's connections to the
Knights of Hyrule and even their
possible connections to the dark nut
enemies check out the theory of mind
about just that anyway after the hero of
Hyrule defeat scan and who fights him
with the power of the Triforce he goes
on to have a few more Adventures the
first of which is Link's Awakening which
used to take place after the Oracle
games but now takes place before them
because Nintendo just decided to swap
around the timeline like that probably
to prove he doesn't die at sea after the
game ends but anyway that adventure
takes place while link is sailing away
from Hyrule in search of Adventure
elsewhere within a dream of a wind fish
but eventually he does go on some real
adventures in the lands of holodrum and
librina in the Oracle of Seasons and
Oracle of Ages games respectively he
also meets two girls known as DIN and
nehru in those lands which is definitely
some potential Theory material the next
playable link and the third to last is
the new hero of Hyrule link number 10.
this link is once again not proven to be
connected to the previous link the first
year of Hyrule though I guess either one
could be a assumed since the spirit of
the hero was never split off from this
reality but rather was just killed as
the hero of time previously it can be
assumed that every hero in the child and
Fallen timelines are all incarnations of
said spirit so whether or not they're
related by blood isn't really important
the new hero of Hyrule solves both
Laurel and hyrule's problems regarding
their triforces and then goes on to have
another fashion emergency Adventure in
Triforce Heroes which despite the name
has actually nothing to do with the
Triforce there are also two other links
that accompany the new hero of Hyrule in
this adventure but literally according
to Nintendo it cannot be known who they
are or where they come from perhaps
their links from other realities I mean
the entire Fallen timeline is a
different reality that happens if the
hero of time is killed so what if we you
know what I'm gonna stop there actually
the second to last playable link and the
last one with a confirmed location on
the timeline is the original hero from
the original Legend of Zelda and I mean
original hero as in the first one we saw
in real life on the timeline however
he's actually quite futuristic this link
is literally a 10 or 12 year old swords
boy who impa Zelda's assistant is saved
by when she was attacked by ganon's
henchmen it just so happens that she had
been tasked with finding a capable man
of Bravery to lead the fight against
ganon's forces and save the kingdom and
with link showing such skill at such a
young age and nobody else really being
around she thought ah what the hell and
asked him to save the land the Triforce
and the princess altogether all of which
he does of course once again though
we're back to having no mention of his
parents at all which should surprise no
one at this point this link also goes on
to another adventure when he's around 16
years of age in the game known as The
Adventure of link where he finds and
awakens an ancient Princess Zelda who
had been put into a magical Slumber by
her brother long ago fun fact when she
awakens at the end this means that there
are literally two princess zeldas alive
in the world at the end of the Fallen
timeline at the same time fun stuff the
final playable link and the one most
fresh on everyone's memory and the one
with the biggest and most blue eyes of
them all would be the one the only the
hero of the Wilds known for for his
adventures and sick climbing skills in
breath of the wild wild Link's father is
actually directly referenced for the
first time ever in a Zelda game by
Princess Zelda herself and we even have
concept art for him that unfortunately
never made it into the game Zelda claims
that Link's dad was a knight of Hyrule
which makes sense given other Link's
affiliations with the group it even
explains why link himself is in service
of Zelda and the royal family directly
as he simply wanted to follow in his
Father's Footsteps his age is never
outright confirmed but we can assume
that he is the same age of Zelda which
is normally the case in the other games
which would mean that he has just turned
17 by the time the game starts or should
I say 117 as most fans undoubtedly know
the hero of the Wilds takes on the
essence of demise's hateful malice
itself known as the Calamity Ganon and
together with the princess seals it away
once again but who knows maybe that
entire fight was just small potatoes
compared to what's to come in tears of
the Kingdom I guess we'll just have to
find out next may but for now that is
the end of my list explaining briefly
the lore behind every playable Link in
the entire series with a few mentions to
the links not playable in the series did
you know everything mentioned or did you
learn something new or did I leave
something out let me know in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this video
or my efforts into making this video
while I'm on vacation please consider
leaving a like to get it spread around
on YouTube and subscribe if you haven't
already for much much more to come we're
well on the road to 300 000 subscribers
so why not help us get there and reach
some pretty cool lore explaining
benefits along the way you can always
unsubscribe later if you change your
mind also huge thanks as always to My
Fabulous Bandit crew and say hello to
Tetra Zelda Prodigy and Alma R who all
joined up right here on YouTube my heart
and my gratitude goes out to you all
thank you so much for keeping this
channel going that's all I've got for
this one so be sure to follow me on my
Instagram to keep up to date this is
Bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out
[Music]
thank you